so has anyone thought of a good eye of
never something that will kind of make
the audience gasp with this belief that
they've never done it anybody
crazy handy oh there are some hands
going up
what have you never done um
eat big things sorry i've never had
baked beans you've never eaten a baked
bean
but they look delicious
but you don't know you've never tasted
them
oh and a chemical sauce
delicious
who else who else
oh man here what have you never done
i've never eaten beetroot are you irish
as well yeah and are you irish geez
irish people are useless aren't they
if it's not a potato i don't want it
[Applause]
piano casually asking to go into space
you know it's cheaper than the bus now
it's a pound go to dublin eat beetroot
who else oh lady right at the back
you're miles away what is it this better
be good
is it good i've got i've got a few steps
to go
all right
what have you never done i've never read
or watched harry potter or lord of the
rings
that's good
well worth the climb
there's someone else here look at you
you
i've never seen any matrix movies
oh
oh my god i can't believe you said that
if it was a nice one
does it involve a guest on the show then
you're allowed to go
uh i've never done any ironing
that's pretty good
that was said with a worrying degree of
pride as well
i bet keanu have you ever ironed
anything i bet you haven't yes of course
have you yes have you yes i don't
believe you i heard my shirts
yeah when i started yes
what have you ever done i have never
kissed keanu reeves
[Applause]
you never will
well done
[Applause]
[Music]